he can beat box
and bike
at the same time
which i think we need to put that to a
challenge they don't have a bike
i didn't think so all right so everyone
please welcome dr yaroon
i'm going to be showing you a word and i
would like you as a group
to say out loud the color
that the word is printed in so not the
word itself but the color this is known
as a stroop test and just to test
whether you are actually awake we're
going to do this as a you know a group
experiment right so in this case you
would say
all right thank you all right
oh there was a black there right all
right
all right you got it
yeah so so this little uh psychometric
experiment was brought to you by r and a
new package that i'm working on called
ray liver
and i want to tell you all about this
but first i want to say a few words
about myself so that you know where i am
coming from now i am first of all not a
game developer
i used to be in academia focusing on
machine learning specifically anomaly
detection after that i worked as a data
scientist at a couple of new york city
startups
during that time i also had the
opportunity thanks to jarrett
partly to write a book data science at
the command line and when i got back to
the netherlands about seven years ago
that actually led to me starting my own
company data science workshops where i
give corporate training
to researchers and developers about r
and python and machine learning and data
visualization
um but a couple of months ago i was
asked to give a
programming and python workshop to a
bunch of 15 year olds
and so while of course
programming is a lot of fun i knew i had
to bring something extra to the table so
i stumbled on this
this c library called raylib
which is a low-level
api
to do anything related to video games
programming
it supports real-time 2d and 3d graphics
music audio
um
animated models
uh stereo
projection vr headsets you name it it's
physics simulation collision detection
you name it very much batteries included
runs on many different platforms and it
has over over 50
language bindings
including python
so um
and you know now also are but let's go
back to that uh that workshop
to show you what we actually implemented
so it was a two-day workshop in the
first day we
introduced you know the basic concepts
data structures and and uh control flow
and so forth
and on the second day you know with a
little bit of guidance these 15 year
olds were actually able to implement
snake
and
it turned out to be a great success we
only
needed
about
10 functions yeah so
um it doesn't get into your way you can
still focus on python
very much while still building you know
an awesome game yourself
here's another example
and this this one is implemented in r
[Music]
i agree that the music is indeed a bit
gimmicky
[Music]
but with these 3d graphics you actually
have all the ingredients to build your
own say
reinforcement learning environment if
you wanted to
but why should you all care about this
right how is video game programming
useful for working with data and
algorithms
so on the left here we have these
components related to video game
programming and on the right we have
uh you know the awesome model for data
science
so besides education and conducting
psychometric experiments like we just
did i think that you know having
real-time graphics and keyboard and
mouse interactivity can be useful for
understanding you know your algorithm
exploring your data
right so here's a here's a more
serious example
that i created
who's familiar with the mnist data set
of handwritten digits right it's used a
lot so but that's not the point here the
point is
um
that it's a high dimensional data set in
order and in order to get insight into a
high dimensional data set you can apply
dimensionality reduction the algorithm
that i'm using here is called umap
and usually you're interested in the
final result
but sometimes if you want to have a
better understanding of an algorithm
from a qualitative point of view and you
want to really know what's going on
under the hood it might be useful to
show you know intermediate results as
well
so in this little tool
implemented again in r and ray liver
you can explore
what this algorithm is doing and how
data points really look like under the
hood so we see all these clusters here
what's interesting is that fours and
nines really do look alike so in this
sub-optimal result we see that fours and
nines are still
um you know close together
on the left we have a cluster of ones
remember these are all handwritten
digits and this algorithm has no notion
of what the true class is it's only
looking at the well the raw pixel values
so what's rey liver it's an our package
that wraps rayleib right the c library
using rcpp
now it has a lot of functions and so
what i did i didn't want to translate
this by hand i created code to do this
translation most of them are
generated by parsing the function
definitions
and this is the minimum amount of code
that you would need in both python and
are
right right is ray liber an anagram of
library
that's genius yeah so you can see that
you know it's it's pretty low level
snake ace yes jared snake case so and
you may notice that you can actually use
our native colors here so i want to
one of my goal is to have this library
as close to you know the r experience
as possible
here's an example of translating a
function definition to the corresponding
c plus code and documentation
again going from pascal case to
snake case
and thanks to the uh you know the power
of rcpp wrappers you can use uh regular
vectors instead of these uh ray lib
defined structs called vector two vector
three and vector four right that's all
hidden from you so you don't have to
worry about this this is this is the
code inside the package
now one open question that i have i mean
there are many design choices that you
still have to make is enums right uh in
rayleigh there are all these constants
hundreds of them and i thought it would
be nice to have those grouped into named
lists but i'm always open to suggestions
there's there's some related work of
course
if you don't really care for
interactivity but you want to create
beautifully rendered
stills and animations there is a package
called ray render by tyler
and he also built ray shader which is
specifically for creating beautiful
three-dimensional maps
and recently mike fc
he's been working on a package called
event loop which kind of does the same
as rayleigh but then
um
not wrapping a c library it's more
bass r that you would need there's still
some dependencies um but yeah you can
also check that one out uh similar
vision i would say and uh he's also
working on a package called tickle which
wraps a tc ltk to build gui's in r
and of course not let's not forget shiny
right now i saw this tweet a while ago
by albert rapp and this really resonated
with me he you know in order to better
understand an equation he created a
shiny application so that he could
interact with uh with several of these
components
right it's pretty useful
so
to summarize
um i think that you know video game
programming
can be useful for when you're working
with data on algorithms i'm of course
not expecting any triple uh aaa games to
come out of the art community uh but
when you're you know uh when you teach
or when you're exploring data or you
want to conduct psychometric experiments
um right or better understand algorithms
with you know a little bit of code you
can whip up you know something quite
fast
um
like i showed you there are plenty of
other tools available for this and
perhaps you know ray liber one day two
so you might be wondering like where is
the github repo well it's still private
you know because
it's um
i know from experience that releasing
something into the open uh does come
with a responsibility and that's
definitely not all fun and games so this
is already pretty niche and if i'm the
only one who finds this uh you know
exciting then
you know i might as well not
break you know put it out there
but if you are interested if more people
think that this is useful
then i might or we might
so you should definitely then come talk
to me uh if you are interested
should we should we do one more um
one more demo
let me see here
there we go
so my my friends are always envious of
my mad beatboxing skills
and you know i tried to teach them but
you know they just can't so what i did
is i went into a studio a couple of
weeks ago met up with an old friend and
we recorded uh some beatboxing samples
yeah you know it's a fun side project of
course
so uh what i did i now have 52 uh
samples and i mapped each of them to uh
lowercase and uppercase letters so that
you can do
you know things like uh
let me see does it have focus
oh let's turn that volume up yeah all
these samples are are indeed my own
voice
[Music]
it's so much fun
and my kids love it too
oh sorry
[Music]
all right thank you so much
thank you
folks uh just huge round first talking
three years at this conference it's a
huge round
so i'm going to bring up our next
speaker on stage as soon as i figure out
how to deal with this clock
you